[Música]
[Aplausos]
la primera vez que pensé en ser pediatra
mi mente automáticamente dijo no no
hagas eso no hagas eso porque la
pediatría es maravillosa trabajar con
infancias es lo mejor que te puede pasar
pero también las infancias les pasan
cosas tristes y eso es muy duro sin
embargo el deseo pudo más y ahí me
sumergí en ese mundo maravilloso de arco
iris huracanes dibujitos
fue increíble en medio de todo eso que
embarazada en primer hijo juan martín lo
está haciendo la residencia y aún así
tuvimos la suerte de tener un embarazo
tranquilo sin demasiados sobresaltos sin
embargo su llegada fue abrupta
fue triste incluso un mes de
neonatología y nosotros sus más padres
que éramos pediatras pasamos del otro
lado empezamos a ver desde adentro cómo
se mira una máquina con números con el
cuerpo de tu bebito
lleno de villas sino de
estudios sin embargo tuvimos la enorme
suerte de volver a casa y pasamos los
seis meses más hermosos de nuestra vida
juani va creciendo y va sonriendo se iba
desarrollando
y en ese momento lamentablemente
volvimos a la terapia intensiva una
enfermedad muy grave muy abrupta que de
todos modos creíamos que íbamos a
superar faltaban pocos días por volver a
casa estábamos ya con el corazón más
liviano
y de repente nunca más volvimos
cuál es pero muy rápido de un día para
otro su cerebro dejó de funcionar
y nosotros entendimos que le había
tomado una decisión nosotros queríamos
criar un hijo y mi hijo libre
y le dimos la libertad de elegir le
dimos la mano y lo dejamos ir
mi primera pregunta cuando juan murió
fue si podía donar sus órganos a veces
no se puede pero en este caso si podía y
juan le dio vida a otras seis personas
cuando nosotros decidimos ser una
familia donante empezamos a escuchar un
montón de frases y un montón de
preguntas que naturalmente tienen las
personas alrededor de esto
hay muchos mitos alrededor de la
ordenación de órganos
el mito más común es que si sos donante
no se van a esforzar en salvarte el
equipo médico no se ha esforzado en
salvarte sino que te va a dejar morir
la realidad de esto es que si un equipo
médico deja deja a una persona morir la
persona entra en falla multiorgánica y
sus órganos no van a servir para una
donación de órganos
el segundo mito más común sobre esto es
que pasan me pueden sacar los órganos
estando vivos y acá nos vamos a meter a
hablar de algo que es muy duro que es
hablar de la muerte y muy misterioso la
muerte tal como la conocemos el paro
cardiorrespiratorio implica esto no un
cese de las funciones cardíacas y
respiratorias pero hay otro concepto que
es el de la muerte encefálica la muerte
encefálica es el cesid irreversible de
todas las funciones cerebrales el
cerebro no le puede decir el resto del
cuerpo que el corazón tiene que latir y
que los pulmones tienen que moverse una
persona con muerte encefálica no está
grave no está muy enferma
no está esperando que suceda algo sino
que es una persona que ha fallecido
recién se habla de donación de órganos
cuando la persona ya tiene un
diagnóstico de muerte encefálica
mi hijo cuando falleció que yo sé
exactamente el momento en el que
falleció dejó su cuerpito y su cuerpito
estaba sostenido por máquina su corazón
latía pero ella no estaba sin ahí es
cuando empiezas el proceso de donación
de órganos
un mito muy común es el tema de el
tráfico de órganos
yo no quiero golear porque tengo miedo
del tráfico de órganos y la realidad es
que el proceso en argentina es muy
transparente justamente hay ley es muy
rígido hace alrededor del tema y esto
lleva a que la donación de órganos
incluso un proceso burocrático que yo
les puedo contar como familia
atravesarlo es duro pero justamente
garantizar la transparencia del proceso
les puedo contar también cuando vine a
una medida mijito para ver cuáles eran
los donantes compatibles porque
justamente implica una transparencia en
esto
el cuarto mito más común es que los
ricos y famosos avanzan por la lista de
espera mientras que las personas comunes
tienen que esperar más tiempo para
recibir un trasplante
hay una lista de espera pero esa lista
de espera es dinámica y no hay una
numeración a priori de las personas que
están esperando un órgano tiene que ver
con el donante tienen que ver con la
compatibilidad tienen que ver con la
distribución geográfica es algo
realmente muy dinámico
existen hoy por hoy las redes sociales y
se difunden muchas veces pedidos de
donación de órganos y esto es muy
interesante porque realmente muestra que
hay muchas personas que viven su vida
esperando una mejor calidad de vida y
más años de vida y esto inclusive en
niños muy pequeños y a niñas muy
pequeñas sin embargo todas estas
cuestiones no tienen que ver con quién
va a recibir antes el órgano porque el
sistema funciona por fuera de esto
hay trasplantes porque hay equipos
excelentes equipos que trabajan en
trasplante pero sobre todo hay
transplantes gracias a que hay personas
y familias donantes
y realmente hacer una familia donante
implica tener información yo era una
privilegiada la información yo nunca
dudé yo agradecí que mi hijo pudiera ser
donante de órganos y porque tenía la
información y por eso estoy acá parada
para compartirles esta información
porque los mitos son muchos y muchas
vidas podrían ser salvadas si no
existieran estos mitos entonces les
propongo charlar de esto en casa buscar
desenmarañar esos mitos que están por
todos lados comunicar responsablemente
en los medios si bien en argentina
tenemos la ley de donante presunto en la
cual todos los mayores de edad somos
donantes a menos que expresemos la
voluntad contraria es importante que
nuestra familia lo sepa y sepa por qué
lo queremos hacer y pueda contar sus
miedos y encontrar las respuestas a esos
miedos
yo te invito a que leas este informe que
comuniques por qué
el adiós a otros seres queridos es
inmenso toda la vida va a ser un duelo
todavía lo vas a recordar con infinito
amor
pero de la muerte se puede dar vida
porque el amor no se muere sino que se
multiplica
[Música]
[Aplausos]